I just broke up with my daughter's dad
oh a little bit ago he had a baby with
someone else while we were together oh
that's not nice we had to kick him out
Martha Stewart telling it like it is
it's a mess Kris Jenner invites the
famed Homemaker over to her house to
surprise her daughter Chloe who's a big
fan during the latest episode of the
Kardashians Martha Stewart isn't that
crazy a little back story the famous
momager thinks that buying a peacock
like the one Martha has will cheer up
Coco amid the ongoing drama with her ex
Tristan Thompson yes a real live peacock
tune in because you never know what's
gonna happen so Chris has Martha over
for lunch and when the good American
founder shows up she freaks out over
their A-list guest I love Martha Stewart
I love entertaining I love organization
I love animals I love flowers I love all
those things I also love that Martha is
not a snitch and it's like my kind of
gal yeah who could forget when Martha
went to prison for five months for
insider trading anyway the ladies sit
down to have a little lunch and that's
when the combo shifts to Chloe's
personal life I don't read and watch all
the stuff so do you have a husband I
don't oh I don't I just broke up with my
daughter's dad oh a little bit ago he
had a baby with someone else while we
were together oh that's not nice we had
to kick them out it's not nice that is
not nice it's awesome it was very nice
and the best reaction to Tristan's
cheating scandal goes to Martha oh
that's not nice we had to kick him out
of course this all comes after the
season two premiere of the Kardashians
where Chloe got emotional opening up for
the first time about welcoming a second
child with her ex it was definitely very
angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled I love that the episodes are
more a little bit documentary style and
I think that you have a real insight
into what the girls are doing not only
you know what you see in the press or
whatever but what's really happening
behind the scenes what is in the media
is sort of things that we feel we need
to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives Coco revealed that
she did an embryo transfer to have a
baby via surrogate just days before news
broke that the NBA star had fathered
another child with another woman
claiming that Tristan knew he was having
a baby with someone else when he pushed
her to move forward with the surrogacy
process it's just so close I wouldn't
want anyone to think I did this after
the fact
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else of course Chloe and
Tristan who also share a four-year-old
daughter true split after his latest
infidelity and welcomed their newborn
son in August
[Music]
thank you